[Musique]
bonjour à tous ça y est il ya quelque
temps au nord a officialisé le lancement
de son nouveau smartphone le au nord 9
en europe et plus particulièrement pour
nous nous intéresse en france c'est donc
un smartphone qui était annoncé il ya
quelques temps en chine on attendait
effectivement la sortie en france
normalement c'est un produit qui aurait
dû sortir au mois d'août mais qui a été
avancé effectivement au mois de juin
on va regarder plusieurs fois on
regardait déjà premièrement on va parler
du produit en lui-même les
caractéristiques techniques cette année
déjà au nord a sorti son huit pros
l'année dernière le au nord 8
là on est sur le haut noir 9 on va voir
un petit peu qu'est ce que ce 9 apporte
de neuf justement par rapport aux autres
modèles
on va effectivement s'il parlait de la
stratégie de honor un savoir comment est
ce que au north se positionne et quel
est le coeur de cible qui est ce qu'il
cherche effectivement à atteindre
au travers de ce produit
car
ça me sauverait le flashy
on a tout de suite commencé par faire un
tour d'horizon de ce nouveau produit le
au nord 9
comme j'ai pas ce produit on va regarder
la fiche technique avoir un petit peu ce
qui est disponible sur le sur le site de
honor et puis je me remets à mes
différents confrères j'ai pu jeter des
coups d'oeil à différents commentaires
sur sur différents sites de high tech
que je peux suivre et notamment avoir un
petit peu leur retour et leur retour
d'expérience par rapport à ce produit
d'ailleurs je fais un petit coucou à en
ordre si vous souhaitez le faire
parvenir un produit pour l'essayer c'est
avec un grand plaisir
c'est un produit qui était présenté à
berlin le 27 juin dernier dont canada
touche fait la vidéo c'était il ya
quelques jours c'est un produit qui
s'inscrit dans la lignée des différents
produits que fait au nord avec une ligne
qui lui est particulière un
environnement et des choix stratégique
qui lui sont particuliers et qui font
aussi son succès dans l'hexagone
il a une façade arrière en verre il est
incurvé
il a un écran 5,15 pouces en 1920 par
1080 avec une résolution de 428 ppp il
dispose d'une puce kirin 960 cadencé à
2.4 gigahertz et de 8 heures 4 gigas de
ram et 64 giga de mémoire de stockage
qui peut monter jusqu'à 256 grâce à une
carte microsd
alors il ya quelques différences par
rapport à son prédécesseur notamment le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui était
situé à l'arrière de l'appareil qui est
passé à l'avant au niveau du bouton de
déverrouillage alors chacun ses goûts
infecte mans il ya des personnes qui
préfèrent un déverrouillage par
l'arrière certaines parlent avant c'est
tout une question de goût mais d'un
point de vue pratique je trouve ça
plutôt pas mal qu'ils soient situés sur
la rue le gros point fort qui est mis en
avant par au nord sur ce produit c'est
effectivement la capacité de faire des
photos de qualité en faible luminosité
il faut savoir que sur son appareil à
l'arrière au nord 9 propose deux caméras
une en couleurs de 12 mégapixels et une
monochrome de
mégapixels c'est effectivement la
combinaison de ces deux qui va permettre
de faire des photos de meilleure qualité
et surtout de pouvoir travailler à
faible luminosité
a contrario la banque propose une caméra
à 8 mégapixels qui bond sera correct a
priori pour faire des selphy mais de ce
que j'ai pu lire à droite et à gauche il
n'y a pas une vraie netteté au niveau
des contours mais par contre ça fait le
job
ça reste quand même relativement correct
contrairement à l'honneur 8 le nord 9
permet de faire de la vidéo en 4k et
pour ceux que ça intéresse il ya un
logiciel de montage dédié quick vidéo
c'est le nom de l'application qui vous
permettra d'une manière assez simple de
monter quelques vidéos rapide et puis
les partager avec vos amis sur les
différents réseaux sociaux aux normes 9h
fonctionne sur android 7.0 de nougat
avec une surcouche le mi5 points il
dispose d'un bluetooth 4 points 2 on
peut y intégrer une double carte sim
très intéressant pour les usages
professionnels et particuliers ça évite
d'avoir un double appareil de l'usb type
c et on retrouve une batterie à 3200
milliampères heures qui a priori
permettrait d'avoir une autonomie d'à
peu près 16 heures quelque chose de
somme toute assez classique qui devrait
bien fonctionner au nord annonce une
charge rapide ce qui fait que en
quelques minutes vous retrouverez
rapidement beaucoup d'autonomie sur
votre smartphone
[Musique]
il est proposé en trois coloris le bleu
saphir qu'on connaît déjà le glacé greek
et la nouvelle couleur que souhaite
mettre en avant au nord et le bim
dagblad smartphones qui a conservé une
prise jack alors que de nombreux
constructeurs ont fait le choix
carrément de la supprimer pour passer
sur du bluetooth et comme on l'espère en
tous cas points 2 ça reste quand même un
petit peu limité il faudra bluetooth 5.0
pour pouvoir effectivement optimisé
utilisé d'une manière complètement
optimale l'audio sans fil très
clairement au nord et sur une cible
jeune ils veulent vraiment cibler un
public donne un public qui a fait leur
succès notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
on sait très bien que au nord si vous ne
le savez pas c'est la fille d'une
filiale de huawei honor travail avec un
budget de communication et marketing
extrêmement restreint et leur
communication se fait essentiellement
sur les réseaux sociaux
la sib et de jeunes disciples des gens
qui veulent faire des photos et des
vidéos de qualité pouvoir partager avec
une communauté ils ont lancé les
accessoires pour élargir leur gamme
toujours connecté avec l'honore 9 2
casques audio dont un avec le fabricant
monsters qu'on va pouvoir retrouver à 49
et à 69 euros et un bracelet connecté
pour pouvoir faire du sport tout en
sachant qu'il y a en ce moment une offre
de lancement sur ce téléphone avec
lequel vous allez pouvoir choisir des
accessoires qui vous seront offerts et
notamment ce bracelet pour le sport
alors puisqu'on parle de prix il faut
savoir que le au nord 9 est un petit peu
plus cher que le au nord 8 à son
lancement il est proposé au tarif de 4
129 euros par contre en ce moment pour
lancement il ya une offre de
remboursement de 30 euros ce qui fait
qu'il est positionné au plus d'eau dans
8 à 399 euros
et si vous allez sur le site de nort
vous verrez qu'en plus de ça à 399 euros
vous allez pouvoir avoir en plus un
accessoire supplémentaire disait
notamment ce marasme est connecté
et
[Musique]
au nord est une filiale de houaïlou et
ai weiwei à une technologie audio qui
est plutôt sympa et que au nord a
récupéré dans ce produit l'honneur 9
c'est le moyen des histones trois
dessins sont seulement si vous voulez
c'est effectivement un son spatialisé
qui vous permette vraiment d'optimiser
complètement l'audio de ce produit il ya
très clairement une grande montée en
puissance de au nord en europe et
surtout en france
la france est le pays honore fonctionne
le mieux en europe
ils ont une vraie base de clientèle une
très très belle progression
pas étonnant effectivement avec des
produits qui sont quand même somme toute
assez sympa pour des prix même si c'est
pas le moins chères sont des prix qui
sont très corrects par rapport aux
technologies et par rapport à ce que
propose ce produit ne peut pas dire
qu'on est sur le produit low cost mais
on est effectivement sur un produit qui
en tout cas semble être de bonne facture
sont l'honneur neuf parce que je ne les
ai pas testé mais par rapport aux autres
fabricants comme samsung et apple on
n'est pas du tout dans la même gamme de
prix il ya effectivement des téléphones
qui sont moins chers si vous allez sur
l'exil me dont on est vraiment sur un
produit qui est vraiment sur
l'entre-deux entre l'entrée de gamme sur
des xi a omis ou d'autres produits qui
vont effectivement vont pouvoir
fonctionner mais qui seront pas cher et
par rapport à d'autres produits que vous
proposez des technologies beaucoup plus
complexe mais qui par contre en terme de
prix tout de suite ça s'envole le au
nord 9 fait office de télécommande
universelle ce qui va vous permettre
active mandat de piloter tous les objets
de la maison on voit très bien que ce
produit cherche à être placé au centre
de tous les objets connectés comme on
peut le retrouver d'ailleurs sur toutes
les stratégies mobiles en règle générale
aujourd'hui un smartphone c'est plus
simplement un objet de communication que
ce soit en direct à du téléphone avec
daily mail sur des réseaux sociaux c'est
vraiment l'objet au coeur d'une
stratégie numérique qui doit piloter
l'ensemble des technologies et
l'ensemble des objets connectés et de
votre vie connectée de votre vie
numérique honor va dans ce sens un
effectivement on est sûr de l'infrarouge
donc avoir piloté une télé pouvoir
piloter différentes choses avec cette
technologie
mais une fois de plus il cherche à
s'inscrire au centre de cette stratégie
pour que votre smartphone soit le coeur
de votre vie
cal quand on connaît les différents
produits des eaux d'or et puis notamment
ses prédécesseurs on voit très bien que
ce produit a l'air d'être plutôt sympa
sur un budget qui n'est pas complètement
déconnant même si effectivement joue la
corde 429 euros
ça reste quand même un budget un budget
conséquent c'est pas gratuit
mais voilà ce ce produit a l'air de se
tenir d'être plutôt de bonne qualité on
en reparlera ultérieurement si j'ai la
chance de pouvoir le tester et l'essayer
directement je devrais me sentir
vraiment merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser des commentaires
pour nous dire ce que vous pensez de ce
produit est ce que vous avez déjà testé
des produits aux doors ce que vous en
possédez en est ce que vous envisagez de
faire l'acquisition d'un de ses produits
à l'avenir
dites moi tout on en parle en
commentaire et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt merci a bientot et ciao
[Musique]